were you excited for video games in 2015
looking forward to playing all those
sweet new titles on your shiny new
next-gen console well it looks like you
might have to wait a bit longer Remedy
Entertainment quantum break is being
pushed back to 2016 microsoft hasn't
given a reason for the delay to the game
other than to say that with so many new
games launching this year moving quantum
break 2 2016 extends our incredible
portfolio into next year with a monster
new IP still the move isn't all that
surprising head of Xbox Phil Spencer
previously said that Microsoft's 2015
lineup was already oversaturated and the
company might need to move something
then answering the totally successful
and definitely not catastrophic x1
reveal event in 2013 quantum break was
designed to sit alongside a live-action
TV show developed by Microsoft Xbox
entertainment studios while the studio
has since shut down Microsoft has
confirmed that the TV show counterpart
remains in development remedy creative
director Sam Lake also shared his
thoughts on the quantum break delay
saying we thank our fans for their
patience and want them to know that the
team has taken advantage of this
opportunity to polish and fine-tune the
game so another day and another big
release push back to 2016 well what do
you guys think should developers get the
time they need to make their games great
or should they just be a little bit more
realistic with their release windows let
us know in the comments below and for
more your gaming news keep it gamespot